that is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armories museum in the uk and i'm dave
jewett the host of loadout the gamestop
show that delves into pop culture's most
iconic weapons and on today's episode
we're going to be talking about some of
the unusual design quirks of the m1
garand the rifle that won world war ii
and get ready to duck
[Music]
didn't quite manage to catch that one if
i got that it worked
if you like this kind of content please
make sure to subscribe as we have
episodes of loadout going up every
sunday including our full episode on the
history and impact of the m1 garand from
last week it was a tool that helped the
allied fight in the second world war
however its modern popularity is mainly
spurred on
by this sound
always wanted to do that
on top of that we'll still be blowing
jonathan's mind with a variety of gaming
guns every saturday so make sure to
check out those too god i think this is
a garand what have they done to you
right let's get to the chat
[Music]
so now we've got one in front of us can
you show us where exactly the ping
comes from
i can now normally of course you load a
full clip of eight rounds
but rather than fling
fairly solid rounds towards your head
i'm going to set that aside i appreciate
that and i'll load a an empty clip so
sort of simulating the end of a string
of fire
so we'll set this up by
locking the rifle open which it does
automatically
put in our empty clip
and then being a little bit careful
load it in bear in mind that when we
fire the last shot in real life you'd
have the last empty case coming out as
well
but the main noise comes from
and get ready to duck
didn't quite manage to catch that one if
i got that it works
so there you go and then it will it will
stay open
so lock to the rear ready for the next
full clip
which you then shove in shove in with
your thumb so as you're loading it it's
worth talking about the
other element that surrounds the grand
of the grand thumb
i don't want you to get garand thumb but
if you can
sort of demonstrate it without hurting
yourself yeah there are other places on
youtube to go if you want to see that
yeah see people willfully hurting
themselves yeah so this is a direct
symptom of
this very clever loading system
in the all you're gonna do is shove in
more
[Music]
rounds and if the the gun is in the
right sort of
battle
the working parts will go forward on
their own even um which is part of the
problem i suppose so to load another
clip or even if you're just trying to
empty the gun and show clear for
inspection um you have to shove your
thumb in it and you've seen
what happens when that slams
shut so you know
you figure it out from there really but
um the weight the way to avoid it is to
use the
the heel of your hand and you take the
clip put it in place
and then using your hand to hold it back
you push in
and then see it's it's wanting to go
forward yeah it's actually hanging up
there because i'm not doing it with
enough authority but
that's what would happen if you're if
your thumb was in it you can see how it
sounds like it would hurt yeah yeah
there's a lot of spring power there's
solid steel flying forward at quite the
rate so if you do it wrong and you don't
put the heel of your hand on there when
you load it maybe you're in a rush
there's a war on after all
you could easily catch the tip of yours
i think that'll be the most painful is
catching the very tip of your thumb in
there it's making my hands feel
uncomfortable
so
loading the unblock clip has its risks
with garand thumb but what is what are
the some of the advantages of
this sort of mechanism um afforded to
you know soldiers back in world war ii
i suppose simplicity um you literally
just carry
bandoliers or pouches actually of
eight round clips shove them in whenever
the they're done the clip gets rid of
itself
um yes you probably want to harvest them
up and reload them but if you're in the
middle of a firefight you wouldn't have
to
um you don't have to faff about
trying to get a magazine fitted
you know certain modern magazine systems
are very efficient at this time less so
it you can kind of struggle to get it in
if you're not well trained well
experienced it can be a problem can't
really go wrong bullets forward shove in
hole
shuts itself or just needs a bit of a
tap to send it forward shoot the rest of
your you know shoot the next clip
carry on and then a very um
you know some weapons will give you a
visible indicator of when they're empty
this gives you a very good audible
indicator you have fired you don't have
to count you fired eight shots get
another clip in
so how come it sort of fell out of
fashion and it's not really something
that's used today some weapons still
have stripper clips but we don't really
see the unblock anymore
yeah the stripper clip has kind of
become a loading device for external
magazines and people who know the m14 or
the bm59 italian garand derivative
with the magazine on the bottom we've
definitely pivoted to attaching a
magazine to the rifle and done away with
the clips
why
partly i guess
exposure to to mud and dirt and things
is a bit worse with these because
they're not housing the rounds in the
same way like then you'd struggle to
kind of pull those quickly and
tactically out of a pouch but more than
anything else it's just the eight round
limitation
you couldn't i don't think you could
really even a genius like garand i don't
think he could design
um necessarily a ten round clip that
would work as well maybe he could have
done maybe i'm speaking out of turn even
then that's only ten rounds it's only as
much as a lee enfield you want 20
30
which increasingly um army's decided
that they did need following the second
world war you've got to make a much
bigger gun
and then you're looking at feeding with
more than one clip like a lee enfield or
more realistically you're going for a
box magazine and that's what they did
great
that still comes out quite a bit yeah
even a loaded clip comes out with a fair
old whack which is why you need like
three hands to try and control it out
keep it for later thank you so much for
watching this episode of loadout if you
enjoyed please do like the video and
subscribe and maybe even let us know in
the comment section down below or on
twitter at a regular dave what you'd
like to see an episode on if you want
more video game firearms content you can
watch the previous series of the show or
check out our weekly series of expert
reacts where i show our friends at the
royal armories a slew of guns to break
down i'd like to introduce you to a
close personal friend of mine here's
what we've got coming up next week on
loadout i get asked quite a bit whether
there is any practical purpose for
something like a desert eagle the answer
is from a military and law enforcement
even a self-defense perspective there is
no
real practical purpose for it it only
gets worse when the barrel gets longer
even the barrel is a deadly weapon
and now
it is time to say goodbye until next
time i've been your host dave dewitt
thanks again for watching and i'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you